but often hey most organizations there
is an office and surprise surprise in
most organizations the senior leaders
they don't do five days a week home
office but they tend to be in the office
a bit more frequently and so this is a
great opportunity to go to the office as
well meet people interact with people
increase your visibility and I'm very
sure that if you look into most
companies and you look at what are the
people that get promoted what are the
people that are not getting promoted
probably there will be some interesting
studies and Academia about this in the
next years but I'm pretty sure that if
you are in the office and make yourself
visible this will definitely not hurt
your chances of advancing your career
and getting designated